Donald Trump's big beautiful wall his
supporters love the idea the primetime
address was the deal maker in chief's
last-ditch effort to sell it to
skeptical Americans at the request of
Democrats it will be a steel barrier
rather than a concrete wall this barrier
is absolutely critical to border
security it's also what our
professionals at the border want indeed
this is just common sense the border
wall would very quickly pay for itself
the cost of illegal drugs exceeds 500
billion dollars a year vastly more than
the 5.7 billion dollars we have
requested from Congress the wall will
also be paid for indirectly by the great
new trade deal we have made with Mexico
poised fact-checkers were quick to point
out that the Democrats did not request a
steel barrier along the border nor would
that new trade deal have any direct
impact on funding for a wall but Trump
isn't one to let facts get in the way of
a good sales pitch once again he painted
those crossing the border as criminals
highlighting brutal crimes committed by
illegal immigrants while statistics show
that crime rate among immigrants is
actually lower than among US citizens
Trump is so obviously more comfortable
at a campaign rally than he is in the
stuffy confines of the Oval Office where
he tried out a softer approach aiming
directly for the heart for those who
refuse to compromise in the name of
border security
I would ask imagine if it was your child
your husband or your wife whose life was
so cruelly shattered and totally broken
to every member of Congress pass a bill
that ends this crisis Democratic leaders
have so far shown zero sign of giving
Trump what he wants to end the
government shutdown and there was no
indication of that changing in there
our own address to the nation sadly much
of what we heard from president Trump
throughout this sense of shutdown has
been full of misinformation and even
malice most presidents have used Oval
Office addresses for noble purposes this
president just used the backdrop of the
Oval Office to manufacture a crisis
stoke fear and divert attention from the
turmoil in his administration
we need border security rather flat
televised addresses contrasted the
heated oval office meeting between Trump
and the Democrats one month ago it's
also a reminder of how little has
changed during that time each side seems
only more entrenched in their own
position talk of Trump exercising
emergency powers did not materialize but
that doesn't mean it's off the cards
right now compromise feels like the
least likely outcome halfway through
week three of the shutdown it's becoming
increasingly hard to see a way forward
Amanda Walker's Sky News Washington